Judicial Watch president tom Fitton he
filed a FOIA investigation request also
investigative reporter Sarah Carter Fox
News legal analyst we count on him
obviously a lot Greg Jarrod is with us
Tom let's start with you and it wasn't
only Weissman
who's praising a woman an Obama holdover
that wouldn't that disobeyed a direct
order of her boss the President of the
United States Donald Trump yeah there
were other lawyers in the Justice
Department senior officials one in the
financial fraud section former US
attorneys who ended up getting fired
in retrospect quite rightly by President
Trump but why spend it's very serious
because he is the number two under
Mueller and he was praising misconduct
by the former acting Attorney General
Sally Yates he was she was fired quite
rightly by President Trump for refusing
to follow his direction to defend a
lawful regulation this this temporary
ban from on immigrants from several
countries so this is a real concern for
anyone who wants fair administration of
justice out of the Mueller investigation
is he like struck compromised
is he a trumpeter because I interpret
that as being a trumpeter and a Hillary
supporter was it you praise lawlessness
against President Trump I think it's
fair to say you don't like President
Trump and he shouldn't be anywhere near
this investigation and it's strike two
in the lease for the Mueller
investigation we've got Peter struck now
we have Weissman and if I were general
Flynn's lawyers if I were man of course
lawyers I'd be screaming to the courts
right now what is going on here why
hasn't this been disclosed struck by the
way he was fired back in July Sean
unbelievable you're and and the Justice
Department his nominal supervisors at
the Justice Department withheld this
information from the American people in
Congress and I tell you it's at the
point where we may need a special
counsel for the special counsel that's
how out of control things are Sarah
Carter you began this all last night
with this guy struck and literally you
know him being removed now we find out
tonight that the girlfriend is removed
and we find out that the number one hit
man with the most atrocious on
go background and record and failure
Andrew Weissman why was he ever
appointed by robert muller with that
background an i know decision the Fifth
Circuit Court of Appeals well I I think
what's most stunning here is his
relationship with Sally Yates and the
relationship among the people inside the
Department of Justice that they felt so
comfortable sharing these emails with
one another on their on their office
email accounts and not only that think
about the relationship he had with Sally
Yates I think there's a serious conflict
of interest here according to a number
of sources that I've spoken with in law
enforcement in the intelligence
community they've said look she was
after Flynn from the beginning and if he
is this close to her and he has this
much respect for her based on a decision
where she basically went against the
President of the United States this
should be called into question and you
know Tom isn't the only one that keeps
saying there's a special cat there needs
to be a special counsel for a special
counsel I'm hearing that a lot right now
I am too Gregg Jarrett you are saying
tonight in a column that Andrew Weissman
must resign or be fired immediately
I don't even why was this man even hired
with that atrocious he wrecked tens of
thousands of people's lives people
innocent people went to jail because of
Andrew Weissman Robert Muller had to
know this of course because Weissman
worked for Muller not once but twice as
Special Counsel for the FBI their
longtime colleagues and friends which is
why Muller hired him and maybe hire
hired him because Muller knew of the
hidden political agenda that Weissman
harbored look not only should Weissman
be fired immediately but the entire
staff of Robert Muller is rife with
corrupt motives and political prejudice
it was entirely stacked against Donald
Trump and so what should happen now
Muller should be dismissed the entire
staff should be fired and a new special
counsel to it should be appointed can do
it while rod Rosen Stein could do it but
he won't do it because he's conflicted
as well
he's both prosecutor and witness in this
case everything
the Attorney General Jeff Sessions who
recused himself from the case should
unruhe queues himself for the sole
purpose of firing Muller and the staff
and appointing a new special counsel and
then disassociate himself from any of
the oversight Tom respond to that I
agree you know mr. Muller is being
treated as if he's king of the Justice
Department he's got this an enormous
budget I guarantee you there's no other
investigation that this Justice
Department is conducting that has the
resources allocated to it that Muller
has and it's being used for what to
investigate mortgage fraud to
investigate a penny-ante perjury charge
render that was a result of an ambush
interview by an enemy of the President
and the supporter of Hillary Clinton we
are ruptured order the Justice
Department of fire Mueller Justice
Department has had their chance to rain
this guy in they haven't taken it and
the president needs to exercise
constitutional options he has to protect
the American justice system between the
the role of structure and the role of
Comey and the role of everybody else
here
call me writing a letter instruct you
know editing the letter they were
exonerated Hillary before they did the
investigation that renders that
investigation meaningless to me where's
the Attorney General where's the special
counsel to do a real investigation
because we know crimes were committed in
this particular case well and I think I
think what we're going to see Shaun is
the inspector general's report and we're
going to see parts of that report before
December we're going to see other parts
of his report coming out after January
and they are looking at Peter struck
they're looking at Comey they're looking
at 27 leakers it would not surprise me
if there is a shake-up at the FBI and
relievers it's coming as soon as for
this week perhaps that's right I'm also
hearing the same and I I think that one
thing that we're lucky with here is that
the layers of this onion have been
peeling back and we've been able to get
information slowly but we've been able
to get information that's exposing it
for what
it is and I think that's the most
important thing right now and it really
it's I've got to lay the foundation then
give the new information so this is
complicated but it's obvious what's
going on Greg what's astonishing is that
one man with a political agenda
exonerated Hillary Clinton and then
simultaneously launched the
investigation because those resident and
call me comic that to me is obstruction
and of course it could be if Comey and
struck ignored incriminating evidence
and instead decided to he'll clear
Hillary Clinton for political purposes
that is obstruction of justice and there
ought to be a case brought against them
if that happened it's a national
disgrace it is what the Muellers team is
a national disgrace it is a travesty of
justice
it's a travesty to exonerate somebody
for political purposes and and literally
before the investigation is done I'm
just out of time we'll have you all back
I promise we're not letting up